what are the doings that to your point
earlier that we can learn from not
competitors yeah yeah but what was it
worthy rival worthy Rivals yeah that are
doing that that you say hey look at that
you know this could be a good uh good
direction well I think most importantly
and you seem to be doing this most
importantly is you see it as a journey
rather than an event I think the
companies that are doing it wrong view
it as an event which is we have this
issue we are not as diverse as we need
to be and so let's fix that flip a
switch you know go in a hiring binge
ta-da right
um and the problem is it's it's that's
not how that's not how it works which is
this is a journey of of making our
organization more representative of the
general population and to say we have to
do better just being just acknowledging
that you're that you there is room for
improvement I think is a big part of it
um but obviously
um um where are you looking to hire who
are you asking to to to make
recommendations
um uh uh all of these things matter I
mean it's literally just opening the
opening the the the aperture one of the
things we have to recognize is we all
have an inherent bias which is we we
look for people who look like us you
know and and to stop doing that
um also go to other companies ask them
who's really good
um but the the the fact that you're
treating is a journey that you will
never actually the point is you'll never
actually be perfect it's going to be a
striving for the rest of time you know
um uh because it's there's three words
there it's diversity inclusion and
belonging belonging comes from your
values and your and your purpose
um diversity comes from what it looked
like but inclusion is how people feel
yeah so it's one thing to hire somebody
but do they feel like they're valued and
included and part of the organization so
all of those are strivings none of those
you'll ever be perfect at none of those
you'll ever complete
um but it is it is a game of constant
Improvement